In case you're wondering, this is a traditional room worn by the Super Family at Christmastime. Until New Year, this is worn from December 21st.
We will join the Super Family as they wake up every morning.
Morning Stacie. Morning. I'm going to go get my grades.
Okay. That's been a long day.
I'm going to test my sound barrier.
I'm going to stop it. Bye Stacie.
What are you going to do today?
I don't know. It's December 22nd.
Maybe we should start getting kids some presents.
Oh, it's not for me.
I've had a cold ever since we got here.
I don't have a cold on Christmas, so I hope it heals fast.
Well, what are you waiting for? Look something up.
I've got some kids waiting.
Hey Para.
I mean, um...
Hold on, let me check.
Okay. What happened to your leg here?
Uh, the baby's twisted it around more.
They're supposed to have spikes on the outside, not the inside.
Or is that just because they're wider?
I don't know. Where's my mask?
Uh, do you want another mask?
Sure.
It's quiet. Definitely.
Hey, my mask just popped out.
There's Bella and Jim making breakfast.
What do you want to do? Put hot to?
Um...
Maybe, uh...
I don't know.
You don't know?
Well, that's very strange for a boy.
Let's see what's up here.
We don't want to spoil the secret of our secret hideout.
Actually, I do want to spoil it because I don't want to...
I know what present we can give the child.
What?
I have very short-term memory.
I forget everything in once a day.
What's she saying? What's she saying? What's she saying?
Do you need any help?
I don't have to get the mask and levitation.
I can fly around by myself.
Hey, Dr. Cedar is holding onto me.
Heh.
You just sit right there?
Back from school, Stacy?
Yeah.
I'm gonna go do my homework.
Hmm.
Oh, great.
Jeez.
Got to search the textbook.
Where is it?
Man, we sure got the tallest tree here.
Huh.
It's stuck.
Ah, right.
Ha ha.
Why do you have to write in Chinese?
Because.
Wow.
Oh, I know somebody who can help you translate.
I know somebody who can really help you translate.
Nakama.
Yeah, she's got...
Can I borrow her on Nakama for a minute?
Sure.
Because I have the mask...
Because she has the mask to translate.
I'll get you a little stuff.
I have it.
Who wants to go paint masks with me?
Oh, help me, G.
Okay.
Paint mask?
Go get the black mask.
Okay.
I got some new paints.
Because I'm gonna open my passport journal, and I don't like to mess up my passport.
Okay.
Before, a black mask.
Where's that brown paint?
Uh, quiet for...
I use one of my friends.
Ha ha.
Because I always read that.
After...
Hattu will really like this mask.
For him.
I have a brown mask.
Brown Akaku one.
Okay.
I'm gonna go get my passport.
What do you got me?
Quiet for Hattu.
Well, I think that's all the paint I've got.
Already?
That's all you've got?
No, no, no, no, no.
So, what kind of Chinese are you working on, Stacy?
I'm just have to write certain words, and she's teaching me how.
She's like my Chinese teacher.
Hm.
She can teach me any language.
I really want to learn Chinese.
But she...
Um, I have a paper, but she lost her book.
Hm.
Put my shrinky dink in.
Turn it up.
Well, I better go get boar, because baby Constance is calling.
This one, this one and this one, um, they're up there because some of you got some papers.
They all look like this, but they're like Chinese or what?
But, we're not changing plans.
Ah.
So, we're going to pass in the paper, take that, and we're going to organize a little.
I thought I heard Baby Sunstripe call.
She's running here.
That's not Baby Sunstripe.
Uh-huh.
We're going to have to give her a little bath.
She's going to jump in the washer, so you get a little therapy.
She's a little poo-poo.
Baby, I have a yellow paper.
Take a little...
Hey, Stacy, what's your favorite?
All kinds of stuff.
What do you mean, what's the main course?
Like, pie.
There's both ones that help.
Both go far in the suit.
Or the pie.
Or don't stand on the stove.
We don't want her.
You can sit in the second socket.
I'll be busy cleaning up, so I guess I'll do the story.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Here come the kids.
Is there any pants?
Sorry, this time.
Don't just do it.
We're going to have two different things.
One for daytime.
Take the night behind here.
I'll cook lunch.
We're cooking lunch.
No, I was cooking snacks.
Remember, Mom's making lunch.
No, she's going to go do the dishes and all that, so I'm just going to...
No, Mom's making lunch, and you're helping.
Yeah, she's washing the dishes up in the kitchen.
And I'm baking for her.
Yeah, and she's going to...
But she's going to call lunch.
Okay.
I told her that, so...
All right.
Kids, why don't you just move in a little closer?
Yeah.
A little bit closer.
Kids, just get a little line.
Don't want to be all spread out.
Like a semi-circle.
A little girl.
A little boy.
Sorry, kids.
Time and time.
It was a little boy.
Okay, now it's tiny.
It's a little boy.
All right, kids, it's time to go to the kitchen.
Okay.
Okay, kids.
Let's get a little...
Okay.
Mom came up.
She had a cup in her hand and a curse in the other.
A little fuzzball was on her chair, before flying in the wind.
Then she threw the sparkles up into the sky.
It was very good that they would have been safe, because there was lots of light in the
He lived in one of the tallest skyscrapers in the whole entire city.
It was blue, and his mother and him always wanted to go to baseball, but his sister didn't
really want to.
One day, his sister was coming up in her bathing suit.
Swimming, she said.
Then, her mother said no and gave her a piece of pizza.
A beautiful dress.
Time for dinner!
The bushes were, and then...
I said it's time for dinner!
Oh, I'm sorry.
Come on, kids!
What's for dinner, Sparky?
We're having all kinds of stuff.
It's a smorgasbord.
It's such a hard to say, isn't it?
It's like a tundish or something.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, we gotta get this table set before they come up here.
I shouldn't have called up for them.
I know.
They're sitting around.
They're just sitting on top of the table.
I'll take it up there.
We haven't come up here yet.
Yeah.
Our back feels so funny.
Roll it off your back.
Nobody knows.
We better get this table set up fast.
Yeah.
I know.
Cheese and cookies.
My specialty.
They're hungry.
We go eat in a different room, kids.
This is your room.
I'll sit with them.
Is that okay?
Yeah.
You know how crazy they get.
I can't.
There's a big jumbo egg for you three to eat here.
My pineapple pie.
No.
You get the cookie delight.
You don't get the big tray.
I forgot two pineapples in the pineapple pie.
Done, kids.
And now.
Yeah.
I'm hungry.
Baby Tess wants corn flour.
Can you go call for her?
Sure.
I'll set these cookies on the table in a while.
I'm ready to go get corn flour.
Can you ask Stacy if her story's finished?
Okay.
Here's baby Matimeo and baby Tess.
Come on, Tess.
Come on, Matimeo.
We got to sit down with you.
You get the big cookie.
You get the soup.
Okay?
We go share.
Yeah.
There's an empty plate.
Fine, I'm going.
Oh, buttercup.
What are you doing over here?
I know what you're doing.
Oh, it's a table.
Look, sí.
And it's comfortable.
It's comfortable.
Well, it's the day before the day before Christmas.
Yeah, it's like...
No, I meant...
It's a couple days before.
It's the day before the day before the day before Christmas.
It's Christmas vacation.
It's two days before Christmassy.
Yeah, so it's like...
Yeah.
Meal.
What did you guys want?
Sorry.
Food.
Sorry, kids.
Your food looks good.
I'm having a clam.
Are you ready?
Do you want me to get a different one?
And my pineapple pie.
I'll just take this chair out and go get my favorite one.
Not too many strict rules here.
Spork.
On quinoa.
Spicy sauce.
Pineapples are good.
Drop some.
On fridge.
Now, where's my food?
Oh.
They taste good with hot sauce.
I need a knife.
You forgot about mine.
Made with a real penny.
Well, I cleaned it up.
Like real.
To eat in a cup.
To actually eat the hot one.
Tender.
So the kids like.
Cause if they, cause if they know it isn't real, they won't eat it.
So.
I'll find you a knife.
The reason I need a knife is because of the tender inside.
This side is the most delicious part.
Just keep it out of this.
Okay.
I guess I cut it with my power.
You want some penny pie?
I need a spoon.
You'd like to put some shell in it?
Wrong end of the fork.
Shell.
One.
Old ones in there that no one drank yet.
It's actually the day before Christmas Eve.
Old spoon.
Here.
Beautiful.
Isn't it bath time?
Y'all ready?
Looks like I found some food.
I guess not.
I hope you kids didn't.
I hope you guys enjoyed this video.
You guys ready?
I, I.
I don't even know.
I wish I could fit in it.
Guess Nala wants my penny pie.
Take your clothes off and got into your bath, or your bath?
Your seats already?
Wait a minute.
One second.
I thought I dumped.
Who in there first?
There's the girl side and the boy side.
No, no, no, no, no.
Stay where you're puttin'.
Why should Baby Sam be on?
Because he wants to be with his sister.
Is she with her sister?
be like right here okay that's where sister and brother is i'll put this in the cupboard
you know and after you get all clean okay we need another book we have another brother and sister
issue here's the shampoo somebody was pouring it on their head while dinner
because it was on the dinner table
this is soap this is shampoo i have to bathe in the shampoo liquid soap and a liquid shampoo
taking the
spaghetti one's out
jess's tail we don't want them growing out like a mouse and don't brush their wings i can brush
hers but not a fripper just be gentle with it because she's got feathers naughty let's go and
play
or you'll get their snack actually yeah i want to brush you two at the same time
to make sure you can brush her her and her and these just your way tony go over here
father louie will be mad if we push all your if we brush up and towel all your feathers away
i'm gonna do you two at the same time did you see that concert today man that was awesome
louie wants mike and one sometimes yeah his next performance is going to be soon
i'm brushing the cupcake maybe somebody can know that first night so the kids are tackling it
because they're pretty hungry oh sorry you gotta be careful with your hair blossom
looks like you got a lot of scared scars yeah her hair is like stiff she puts too much hair
spray take the hat off i need to find her hair doesn't have nerves oh that's the one thing i
don't know well maybe you know it now then she's got a lot of marks on the back of her head she's
needed some conditioning well look you can almost see your skin there's blossom okay be careful with
balls as ponytail sometimes they act like missiles and fly off same with blossoms oh look at the tips
of it just like blossom buttercup's horns don't hurt your hair finally got a little time to break
oh here's a knife and then do you want to redo your dinner no
haha
if that would work
Oh, that whirlpool bath feels cool.
Hey, turn it off!
Where was the electricity?
Well, nobody's having any.
Well, my foot was.
Oh, you got chalk on your head.
Baths are in there until chalk comes off.
It didn't come off. It came off like magic.
This way.
This one's better.
Oh, you can turn it off and use it as a normal bath.
Sparky really likes the old one.
That's what I do.
Look at the kids in bed.
Yeah, they fell asleep.
I'm surprised they fell asleep.
Better put my robe on since I just took a shower.
And I'll turn the stove off.
It is winter.
I'm going to take the kids out sledding tomorrow.
See, he's going to take care of them.
Yeah, that's right, too.
Who falls asleep?
I don't know. It might hang out.
Too bad we don't have TV in the kitchen anymore.
Yeah.
So what table it is?
Um...
I think he's already in there.
Probably in the body.
Let's go to bed now.
Huh?
Now?
Okay, it's time to eat. Okay.
Eat a snack?
Okay.
Oh, man, that was a good snack.
Wasn't it, Stacy?
Yeah.
But I can't get back in my cover.
Where's Spark?
I don't know.
Oh, here she is.
I'll move some weight. You should...
Well, time to go to bed.
It's time to go to bed.
Okay.
Come on, Sparky.
When the rooster calls.
When the chemical rooster calls, Stacy.
Can I sleep in?
What was that?
Might as well get up.
I'm ready to get cooking.
What's that?
No, how to cook.
No, I cook.
Well, whatever. Who gets done first?
Yeah.
Let's just set the table.
See who can turn his coffee the fastest.
Promotion with Dr. Simeon.
He drank too much coffee too fast.
I can see.
There's no coffee for me.
And there's no ice in the ice maker.
What kind of coffee should I get today?
Type A, type B, or type C?
Guess what I got today.
What?
Well, last night.
Oreos.
What do you think I should get this morning?
A for super energetic, B for just normal but you're going to be active, or C just for relaxation day?
Yeah, because we've got to go get the kids.
Where's my camera?
The camera's right over there.
More ice.
I'm fine.
I guess I'll fill you with cold water.
We'll make a coffee, but this time I'll be careful.
Show me to it on your screen.
Sort of.
Want to go shop?
Want to go shop for the kids?
Okay.
This is burnt.
What do we got here?
A stretch.
Maybe some straight.
I don't know.
Or maybe they suggest.
I think.
A nice rocking chair.
Yeah, the kids would probably like it.
Cart stuff over here.
No.
We can just put it in my bag here.
A telescope.
Old time.
We could have used these earlier.
Could have defeated the new Euroma a lot easier.
A green notebook.
I've always blue.
I don't know.
Maybe Grandma Pikachu?
Yeah.
How about we get the hat for just the kids playing with and we get that for Grandma
Pikachu?
All right.
She'll love this.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Kids would get away with looking like a watermelon in this.
Do you think we should have a Christmas tree this year?
Yeah.
Let's get a little mini one.
That's awesome.
Pikachu.
Somebody else.
A piglet.
Piglet.
Yeah.
Pig.
The 500th item on our list?
Hmm.
Only the 531st.
I thought you meant Baby Sunstrike.
We got something for Baby Sunstrike.
That little cute dragon.
Yes.
Now what will be the 532nd item on our list?
This'll be perfect.
997th item on our list.
Do you think we got a little too much stuff?
How about $200,000?
Okay.
Now let's get rid of some of these presents.
Should we only get $1000 of them?
$1000 of them.
Yeah.
How about we get a faster dragon?
What's the next time we're going to a big restaurant to get some lunch?
Put the stuff in the car.
No wait.
Yeah.
We're going to have to get, um...
We're going to have to...
Where's our, um...
Where's our three Wind Stars?
Wind Star Vans.
We can take off all the seats in the back and then we can pack up all the presents and
that so we'll have plenty of room.
We have four Wind Stars.
Okay.
We can just keep the seats in for our passengers.
Yeah.
No, why don't we get that...
That new...
new van that dodge just came out with that one that sees 15 people we have um we have that we
we have um 12 people so we only need one of them how about we use the four one stars for cargo
and then we use the one van for transporting the people who went out went out to get presents
okay the limo but but i want to go buy that dodge how about can we get a viper then because i really
like wipers yeah and can we get those oh no we already won one how about we're pretty i'm pretty
greedy because i just just want punch buttons you can have any allowance for a week it's never
thick it's never thick you got a million dollars okay no you won't be able to buy a punch
when you're dead why punch when he's fussed about like 15,000 bro why don't we go out and buy cars
for everybody in the super family that's an adult our kids have their smuggler cars i live it all
my name you love your life and you love eternity even we'll look for it i tell you we'll always
we'll always be there to protect it it's a loud accent i think um it's permanent
volume if you jack it up a little a little notch it's going to stay like that
i'm still thinking about those cars how much it's going to cost if you're going to buy like 45.
i think that's how many adults and teenagers are getting yeah what are we getting into toa nuva
upgrades the heck are these transform toa reserved for the super family
danger biohazard do not expose to toa
it's a product danger do not expose to tell us they will become evil you could go
to them and let them try it and you can just defeat them if they turn evil because what if
it's a trick but for christmas okay maybe we'll get it we'll try to um to change time
or go back in the top and back in time oh man that was a good lunch
i got a stomach ache those cars now here's a pill that helps you with it everybody talks so quiet
so what car are we gonna get well we gotta get 35 of them let's see i have one for me i have one for
you i have well actually we only need 21. we don't need one for gravity because she is actually we
only need three so what do we get we have one for each hand
why don't we get a kitchen um why don't we get a convertible for the magic family
um how about a ruby red that would be good okay
you already have a blue punch buddy oh you're gonna buy it so it can't get you all right who won
that one that was on the side i did
i did
you need one more because i just realized that we had is my little punch buggy convertible punch
yes now um what kind of stuff do we got uh what kind of car let's just give him a biker for the
last kind of car okay let's head back to the house all right let's go i don't want stacy's coming home
oh the kids are playing with the health board
looks like it
oh what do you suppose we do today looks like grandma pikachu was cooking oh oh oh are you
trying to make shish kebabs again from pikachu yes here i'll help you open that i want to make
radish shish kebab
i'll help i'll help you open the jelly
here i'll help you open that i want to make radish shish kebab
okay what am i making now
radish shish kebab
no it's not radish shish kebabs it's radish shish kebab
i said radish shish kebab
no you're supposed to say it the way i say radish shish kebab
radish shish kebab
that's right
ow i got the beat on my foot
and now to open it
i might as well start cooking dinner while
what should i make this time
how about the super soup
i'll make a super soup this time
are you gonna use the big big bowl
i guess so yeah
wait
i'm gonna use it
i gotta take my soup
okay
soup in a pan
chop
don't need this
my soup seems to be ready except for a few spices
i really need some spices
it's sunday
and we're going to make a soup
in my special super mix of hot sauces
and spices
actually i changed the caps this
i used it all up
let my soup cook for about some tea
let's you have a little
to pour it
it's a good thing i didn't plate my tongue
i'm going to put my soup in
because the hot sauce
it's done
only i can touch it because
if i let it i don't want to spoil it at all
okay
no matter if i trust them
the famous soup
this time
here's some lemonade
and you get
the muffin cake
treat me with real eggs
what do you want to eat
i want to eat french fries
because that's what i need
as i need to charge my brain
here's some soup
there you go
whoa this table is the most crowded
because the adult table
well two adults always have to
eat with the kids each day
you don't have to dread that
they can cook for them too
the adults are so much like
as long as this house
okay but timmy
don't touch my coffee
it's hot
i was looking for you
scorch here's your sister
watch out maybe sam might
steal all the food
what are we having for dinner
i don't know we'll just get some
some electric shock food
i'm gonna give her some young chow
over there
i got my feet
you were trying to steal food weren't you
and sparky was peeking at the presents
here you can sit at your table
there you go
this is nice what is this
well
right below her she thing
is
fudge
there's coconut cream
right here and this is just normal dinner
you can have this turner
whoa this is a pretty crowded table
whoa get off my soda
i know
sam are you sure you want that
i can make you a salad
can i share it with you
i'm gonna carry it all over the calendar again
tonight's christmas eve
i don't think we should have the
tree this time
let's have something different
do you think we should wrap the presents this time stacy
no
but we won't have anywhere to put them
because we don't have a tree
invisible wrapping
we'll put a special coating on it
i just bought it
it makes the kids think it's just a normal box
it makes it look like
it's just a normal box
then when they rip the invisible wrapping off
then they can finally get to the goody present
inside
mine derates for the last two seconds
where are we gonna put them
where we don't have a christmas tree
around
the symbol that we get this year
what symbol is that gonna be
i don't know
it's usual
remember you got that whirlpool tub
when you're done there stacy
get rid of all the food and dishes
and while you're doing that
i'll get all this stuff ready
but i don't wait you yet
ok go clean the dishes and stuff
ok
ok kids
into the bath
now let's just load more
now take the dishes over
to the sink
it was both
i said it was whirlpool
you have to soak in
white soap pinkish
lemon
you towel this time
do it until i'm done here
no i can only do this
now we gotta get the kids
you haven't toweled yet
no i toweled
you can go as fast as you like
it's like paper
darn kid name dexter
tough job you know
why don't you start emptying it here
why don't you start emptying it
emptying it like that
like that
i'll hide it under the kitchen
i'll put it in here
and i'll hide it in here
what happened
because i thought he would leave
i thought he was dead
can you leave any of his stuff here
i'm gonna close this you know
do you know what christmas is really about
you'll find out later
maybe he hid them
why don't you go find some
and a computer for blossom
it was all black
next year
sure that's really nice
hey stacy why don't you clean up the story
that's right
gotta clean that stuff up right
yeah that's what we're doing
it's just
i guess piglet could go on a detective
but i done it
i've been talking really hard
okay just clear it all out
just a different way so it's a lot
you guys get it set up
you get started while i clean this up
probably everybody
okay open the door
go hurry
you guys sit down
you're sitting right
we go
here we go
okay you do it
i gotta go
i'll sit down for the prayer
everybody get ready for the prayer
god is great god is good
thank him for our food by his hands
we are fed thank you for our daily bread
amen that was beautiful stacy
thank you
all right everybody
it's time to scoff
are you eating stacy
i'm reading the paper
kids
my dog
oh i'm sorry
i'm going to go over
very exciting feast though
but it's got
good food
hey somebody passed the famous soup
okay let me get myself some
where's the soup ladle
thank you for passing it
time to eat my delicacy
anybody else want
the famous soup
okay there you go grandma
here's quiet
we are having a dance
well it's dance time
people
here we go
okay
that was a good dance
it was
now we gotta clean up this entire thing
don't we
you know what
we still didn't give the toa their present
but i'm not sure about it
kabaka and
falatu never came home from their little adventure
they are home
but they never came back that is
yeah
hey do you think we should give it to them
hmm
okay we'll give it to them
hope you enjoyed the super family's
sixth movie um return home
please join us on our next video
the seventh movie
um the toa nuva
protoderms
clean up
the toa will be
maybe
till later
that's a show
dishes clean up
come on kids let's go back home
move around pikachu
trash receptacle right away
bye bye
everybody gone
okay good
because my chains are killing me
i gotta smile like this all the time
i mean like
you think i can take a little break
a little break
okay a little break
nighty night
to mention all the others
mysiac
pastel stretch
slim solarize
bnw and sepia
besides neglect art
of um
doctor senior 2000
which is with
which is
a special video
in this it was created in 1999
unlike his brothers
the super family videos which were all
created all six of them were created
in 2002
now here we go
good night
okay honey
no
stacy how you doing
what you doing
that is very strange
i cannot find that pokemon poster
get some apple sauce
we don't have enough food
for them
crash and koko are coming
no
spyro and meg are coming too
are you sure
okay okay
seven what
seven thirty
pikachu i can't get up there
goldilocks went to the
and then she opened the door
she tried to open the door
but it was locked
so she opened the window and jumped in
and landed with a big
on the floor
and she smelled something good
it smelled like porn
stacy what do you want for dinner tonight
pizza or pork
okay pork and pizza
let's call it the pee pee dinner
because pikachu goes like pee pee all the time
okay i'll be upstairs getting the thing ready
you watch for anybody who comes in the door
okay
crash said he might be the first one in
koko said
remember
seven thirty
the party starts
then she smelled some good porridge
she tried the
big bowl
she tried the second one
but it was too cold
but then she tried the small
goldilocks got a little bit tired
she went into the bedroom
she laid on the
first bed
but it was too
but it was too crump
goldilocks wanted to sit down
and watch tv
she turned on the TV
she sat on the first chair
but it was too fast
she sat on the second chair
she got stuck in
and she went into their house
eating in my bars
and baby bears
sat down
they saw the tv was still on
scratched his head
pulled her belly button out
and baby to go to bed
baby bears
said i have to go back to
when they're doing the
chair thing
and um
then
papa bear said
someone's been sleeping in my
um
that wasn't good
oh my god
looking at her picture
didn't take any but i said
hey dr snore
coco isn't it time for the party yet
day call
for tomorrow again
we forgot to have kegan stuff
that's cause we didn't have time
it's a snowstorm
we didn't have time
the electricity's out
and the cake lights up
there's supposed to be lights around it
so the party can't really start yet
work or something
yes i am going to work
see that's where i start
we'll be back
after these messages
what are you doing
why would you be doing that
cause we don't need them anymore
of course we would
why would you say too late
too late
slice of warmed up pizza
paper anymore
it was already cut up in the line
on my pen
cc look at the camera
scissors
that's not how
pika did it
he did
he did it
pika choose that
so she
really hard
where the kids are this morning
not gonna put my
momma
stacy what are you doing this morning
i thought you were asleep
watching tv and eating chips
watching the news
oh i thought you were watching cartoons
where's pikachu
right beside me
hey
hey hey hey
choo choo choo
come here sizer
yo big show
oh here
we gotta find friend kabutops
kabutops too big to play with now
why doesn't stacy help you
well i'll help you this time
i'll be right down
why why why
now i'm shaking the ships
here
stacy you really shouldn't be watching this show
that show
pikachu shouldn't either
she's too little to watch it
maybe i can turn something like cartoons for you
there you guys
i'm not that kind of teenager
pikachu's too little
it's too loud stacy
it's gonna hurt pikachu's ears
there you are
wait a second
i'm gonna turn this up
just like you said stacy
stacy i can tell that's funny
coming in the kitchen with dinah
that won't be up yet
did you stick something on the roof again
i thought i saw something
you've got some very unusual characteristics
wow what
i've had neighbors from his old country
tend to his medical needs
i'm tired to jump on this tree
just overhead
i feel uncomfortable
park me
hold the elevator double d
ah
sun again eddie
cotton gravy
see how'd you like the movie
there's a planters having a party in the next room
come down
look at the pokeballs
over there
he lays off eating something with his friend
i'll check in that room
of course that show last night
was really goofy
pika pika pika
is the party supposed to start tonight
i don't care
where the heck did i put that clock
i got all the paper out
i saw something
couldn't what me
there's a wonderful dinner they have
tonight
last night i mean
i'm still burping
that's a cup of purple sugar
in a bowl
now what does it say
it just says this
it just says a few bits of
corn cereal
gotta go get that
one blueberry too
one blueberry
what's it supposed to do with this thingy
chop it like nuts
this
no i don't think that goes in
it's fireworks
it almost blew a hole in the roof
get that out
are they done
hey what the heck is this
it's pokemon pancake
no it's pokemon not done yet
so weird
wait a second
what
we'll be right up
stacy what are we having for breakfast
i gotta go get to work
while you're leaving
here's your coffee
okay
you better go back into the kitchen stacy
but stacy remember
the party's supposed to start
at 5 30
tonight
the party's gonna be longer
he's trying to attack me i guess
pika whatcha doing
trying to build
a snowmobile
whatcha doing
how you gonna build it
hehehe
pika too
stacy's gonna be in there with you
i've been here before
hey shuttle
see what happened
pika too
pika too if you touch these
turtles
i'm an idiot
stacy is it school today
pokemon school today
yep
remember the party's at
i think 5 45
we're having parties
this is after school
look at sharky
wanna get out
i didn't look
here's your little play thing
play play play
there you go
pikachu let me put you like that
you fly while stacy
combs your hair
stop
you chew
put some electricity in your cheek
the pokemon
right here
trainer with a pokeball but he already has a pokemon in it
and he's protecting you
no
he's just a little lego person
lego did you build him
yeah
except of course we're lego people
shrunken pikachu
pikachu this can be our lego pikachu
and this can be our lego otter
stacy
build the landing pad for the helicopter
and there's somebody landing with
your stuff for your house
we'll check it out
as soon as school's over
ok
stacy isn't the party supposed to be sometime tonight
mess with it
i didn't put it anywhere
it was up there a while ago
see what are you doing
kazoo
never keep that in there
pikachu it was right under you
under there
puff up this hot dog
that's the hot dog
look for somebody else
if you stop eating
you can't make it
i'm gonna sit back here
back there
how do you like the party so far crash
good
right here miss coco
well i don't know missy
cake
you may come to dinner pepper
yes you may
where is uh
fort discovery is
quiet one second
gotta turn this off
they're saying some things
here we're getting some treats
here's the dishwasher
here it is
i clean all these plates up
this pot we'll put some things in the refrigerator
thank you for putting
my stuff in there
the cake was half eaten
say that
stacy did you give the pokemon their vitamins
until um
fill those
alright we'll take these
whoa whoa
i need a refill for this bottle so i'll sit it outside
can anyone
any of the bread and butter
well people did
here stacy
corner
you're so long stacy
look you're so long
it hit
pikachu just wanted to get on a lot of rides
don't you guys got a
party at school today
your mother i don't see what she's making for dinner
but
it's just cereal
that says soda
this says milk
pikachu
is soda good for you
say okay
i don't know
should've been here a while ago
let's wipe some pink
frosting on you
but then our little helper buzz guy came
just plain chocolate
that's pikachu's but you can have some
no sugar
i'll put some sugar in them
i'll put some gel on them
i'll put some jelly on them
pikachu
dum dum dum dum
dum dum
what are you doing dear
putting pictures
i mean pie
what are we gonna do today again
i don't know